دعنا ننتقل الآن إلى إيران حيث
تستمر التوترات في التصاعد ، نحن على وشك أن
نعرض لك مقطع فيديو مزعجًا لرجل
يتعرض للضرب وإطلاق النار عليه ، ولا يمكن لـ CNN التحقق من
وقت تصوير الفيديو ولسنا
متأكدين مما حدث للرجل في
الفيديو  لكن من الواضح أن هذا
موقف عنيف
تم نشر هذا الفيديو على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الآن ويبدو أنه يظهر ضباط
يهاجمون مواطنًا وقد ردت الشرطة الإيرانية
على هذا الفيديو وأصدرت
أمرًا بالتحقيق في الحادث أو
جرمانيًا لمتابعة ما يحدث في
إيران.  نحن من مقرها في
اسطنبول ،
شاهدنا الفيديو الذي شاهده مشاهدو
الفيديو للتو ، هل لدينا أي
تفاصيل أخرى حول ما كان يحدث
في هذه الحادثة ،
لا نعرف حقًا ما كان يحدث
قبل وبعد هذا أه تعلم  هذا
المقطع القصير أه
الفيديو المروع المزعج للغاية الذي ظهر أمس
وتم تداوله على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
بيكي لكنه من تلك
اللحظات النادرة التي لديك فيها فيديو أه
حادثة كهذه  نوع من
الوحشية التي نسمع عنها الكثير
من المتظاهرين
والمدافعين عن حقوق الإنسان في إيران وترى أنها تم التقاطها
بالكاميرا ترى ذلك الرجل على
الأرض يتعرض للضرب بلا رحمة من قبل
قوات الأمن ثم ترى
ضابطًا يصوب بندقيته  تجاهه
وإطلاق رصاصة نسمع أحد الأشخاص
الذين يصورون هذه الحادثة من
مسافة بعيدة يقول إنهم
كانوا منصات بنادق لا نعرف حقًا
حالة الرجل وماذا
حدث له بعد ذلك ولكن كما
ذكرت آخر  لحظة نادرة هنا حيث
لا تنكر الشرطة الإيرانية وقوع هذا
الحادث يقولون إنهم
شاهدوا الفيديو الذي أمروا بإجراء
تحقيق فيه وهم
يقولون إن هذا أه في كلماتهم
لا يوافقون عليه  هذا السلوك العنيف وغير
التقليدي لكن أه الكثير من
الإيرانيين والمدافعين عن حقوق الإنسان
سيقولون لك هذا أه الطريقة التي
تتصرف بها قوات الأمن في البلاد
منظمة العفو الدولية
أه تقول إن هذا غير صحيح
تذكيرها المروع بأن قسوة
قوات الأمن الإيرانية لا تعرف حدودًا
أن هذا قادم وسط أزمة
الإفلات من العقاب بكلماتهم حيث
تُمنح قوات الأمن الحرية في
ضرب أه المتظاهرين بوحشية وإطلاق النار على أه
المتظاهرين مجددًا مجددًا دعوتهم
للأمم المتحدة الإنسانية  مجلس حقوق الإنسان
للتحقيق على وجه السرعة في الجرائم في إيران
بيكي